One of the more confusing aspects of The Nun
is the fact that Valak is constantly manipulating
things, and it’s hard for us as an audience
to get a grip on what’s real and what’s
not.
For the ultimate guide on what exists and
what is just an apparition, stick around to
the end of this video.
I know what you’re probably thinking, “Oh
it’s this guy who jumpscared us, let’s
lock him up forever.”
Look, this video’s not about the jumpscares,
it’s about Things You Missed In The Nun.
Now, I do reserve the right to jumpscare at
any time during my videos, but I don’t usually
pull it out for Things You Missed; all I can
say is to stay on your toes, and let’s get
into it.
Like I pointed out when I made this video,
in The Conjuring 2, the name of the Nun demon
Valak is hidden within many of the scenes
like so…
And that trend continues here in The Nun.
For example, when we first meet Sister Irene
at the religious school she teaches at, when
they show the playground, there is a see-saw
that some kids are playing on.
The bars that makeup the supports of the see-saw
spell out the word Valak.
Then, in Biertan, the Romanian town near The
Abbey, Frenchie has Sister Irene and Father
Burke load their stuff onto a truck.
The license plate of the truck reads VA 01
LAK.
If you remove the numbers, it spells out Valak.
There’s also a crossword puzzle that Father
Burke is seen solving a couple different times
in the film.
Take a look at some of the boxes he’s written
in and you’ll see the words Deliveries and
Create.
I bet you thought I was going to say that
it said Valak, but the fact of the matter
is that the shots weren’t on screen long
enough for me to see everything, so if you
saw anything pertaining to Valak or anything
of significance at all, leave a comment telling
me what you saw, and I’ll pin your comment,
and you’ll be famous and it will be a great
day for you.
So… remember when I did that one video where
I explained the deeper meaning behind the
song that comes on the radio in the commercial
for The Nun?
Well… it may have been all for nothing,
because the song that comes on in the actual
movie is different.
“Just remember darling all the while.
You belong to me.”
The song is You Belong To Me, performed by
Jo Stafford.
Like the song that was used in the commercial,
it’s a cover of an existing song from that
era.
In this case, the song is used as a direct
message from Valak to Father Burke, a warning
that if he stays in The Abbey, he’s in for
trouble.
Valak is literally telling him, “you belong
to me now” and it’s a foreshadow of the
scene where the Father is locked in a coffin
where Valak tortures him.
It sure was nice of Valak to leave that shovel
there for Sister Irene when she eventually
does find the father.
While she’s looking for him though, Valak
lures her into the chapel, where a couple
of interesting things happen.
First off, the Nuns are chanting, so she should
immediately know that something is up, because
we were just told they are taking a vow of
silence.
Then Sister Irene sees a red glowing light
coming up from below the altar, a symbol of
the fires of hell manifesting in the Abbey.
At this point, she follows the shadow of The
Nun along wall, landing on the mirror behind
her, where it is revealed that Valak is standing
above her, however, the figure can only be
seen in the reflection.
Later on, when Frenchie is at the Black Bear
pub back in town, he notices a woman covering
up a mirror.
When he asks about it, the bartender tells
him that a young girl had recently died, and
that it was a tradition in town to cover up
mirrors so that the deceased do not see their
own reflection.
Remember the photo that Sister Charlotte shows
from her time in Romania in Annabelle Creation?
I had previously speculated that we would
meet some of the characters from the photo
in The Nun, however, Sister Maria, Sister
Anna and Sister Lucia do not appear.
This is because Sister Charlotte visited the
Abbey before the events of The Nun took place.
You can actually spot this same photo on the
wall when they come into the Abbey.
Poor Sister Charlotte has no idea that her
friends are all dead.
Another item I speculated on was the relationship
between Sister Irene from The Nun, and Lorraine
Warren from The Conjuring films.
I thought they might be sisters because they
both have visions of Valak and the actresses
who play them are sisters in real life.
In The Nun, no relationship is confirmed,
however, I do find it interesting that The
Vatican selected Sister Irene to accompany
the Father, despite the fact that she is unfamiliar
with the area.
The Father mentions that The Vatican always
has a reason for their selection, so I think
it’s still possible that the two are related
in some way, and that has something to do
with why she was sent.
While we don’t get much background on Sister
Irene, we do get a little bit more background
on Valak.
Father Burke researches to find that The Abbey
was built by a Duke who wrote books and opened
a gateway to hell.
This information may be a nod to the fact
that Valak is based off a character from a
book called The Lesser Key of Solomon, which
I have gone into more detail on in this video.
The Gateway was sealed with the blood of Christ,
but reopened later due to a war of some kind.
Valak appears as a Nun in order to blend in
with the real Nuns that that reside at the
Abbey, so my theory about Valak possibly changing
forms has gained a little more weight.
The other thing I pointed out in my previous
video about the pages of the book was this
illustration, which appears to be a snake
coming out of someone’s face.
The idea of a snake being another form of
Valak is confirmed in The Nun.
Father Burke reads a description of Valak
in the book that he finds inside his coffin,
which reads, “Valak, the defiler, the profane,
the marquis of snakes.”
There are plenty of other instances of Snakes
connected to Valak in The Nun.
The throne thing occupied by The Mother Reverand,
who might I remind you ends up being Valak,
has an image embossed on it of two snakes
eating each other.
When Father Burke chases the apparition of
Daniel into the graveyard during their night
at the abbey, snakes end up coming out of
Daniel’s mouth to attack him.
Closer to the end of the movie, The Father
battles a figure with a serpent-like forked
tongue.
And in the final battle against Valak, a snake
wraps itself around The Father’s neck and
bites him in the eye, which ties right back
into the book that the Father found after
being trapped in the coffin, which features
a single eye on the cover.
There are two facets to the ending that I
want to talk about: one involving the manipulation
caused by Valak, and the other involving,
the true identity of Frenchie revealed in
the very last scene.
First let’s talk about Valak.
Before heading down into the depths of The
Abbey, the characters figure out that there
are no other nuns left, Valak has completely
taken over the place.
It’s a little unclear if the people they
met in the beginning, such as The Mother Reverend
and Sister Oana were alive at some point,
or if they were apparitions of Valak as well.
Here’s my answer.
The only real living human Nuns at the Abbey
are killed off in the prologue.
Everyone we see after that is a distortion
caused by Valak.
Valak poses as The Mother Reverend and tells
Father Burke to stay the night because The
Nuns are currently taking a vow of silence
and cannot speak with them.
This is a trap to get them locked inside the
Abbey.
I mean, the vow of silence thing is kind of
true because they’re all dead.
When Frenchie discovers the body of Sister
Victoria, he mentions that he tried to contact
the Abbey but was unable to reach them.
This is because Sister Victoria was the last
Nun.
We see the body of another one of The Nuns
fall out of a tree and land on him as he leaves
the Abbey, just one of many examples of The
Nun corpses throughout the area.
There’s also one confusing instance where
Irene talks to Sister Oana, but then discovers
her corpse moments later.
Then, Oana seems to be back alive in a following
scene.
The one she was really talking to is just
one of Valak’s tricks, but the body discovered
under the sheets is the real Sister Oana,
who had died several weeks before.
There are many decapitation references that
could link to the death of each of these Nuns.
I already mentioned the one that fell from
the tree, there is also a statue in the main
hall area that the Father is studying in whose
head crumbles off.
When Frenchie saves Father Burke’s life,
he decapitates the zombie nun with an axe.
You’ll also notice that many of the Nuns
that haunt the Father and Sister Irene are
faceless, as is the Jesus figure in the chapel.
Also in the end credits, there is some entity
with a burning head.
The big reveal of this movie is actually foreshadowed
when we first meet Frenchy, as he is seen
at home feeding his goats.
Goats are an animal that are often used as
a symbol of demons and the devil, and the
French-Canadian farmer ends up being possessed
by Valak at the end of the movie.
In the epilogue, we discover his real name
is Maurice and he is the man receiving the
exorcism in the clip Ed and Lorraine show
to their class way back in the original Conjuring.
“Take Maurice here.
He’s a French-Canadian farmer, had nothing
more than a third grade education, but after
he was possessed, spoke some of the best Latin
I’d ever heard.
Sometimes backwards.
A dark spirit made it’s home in this man.”
“And like that, an upside-down cross started
to appear from within his body.”
The big connection to Lorraine’s most feared
memory was five years in the making.
Did you see this twist coming?
Let me know if the comments.
Remember to like this video, and be back next
week as I’ll be discussing where the Conjuring
franchise will go from here.
You definitely don’t want to miss out on
that, so be sure to subscribe to CZsWorld
for new horrors every week, ring that deathbell
for notifications and I’ll see you in the
next one.
Assuming we both survive.